just flux we make any progress all right
and if it doesn't make any progress why
are we wasting time with it it doesn't
seem worth wasting time with for one
thing one has to be able to chew
demarcate the borders between science
and other things this is not something
that for scientists to do this is a
philosophical question how do we
demarcate the border what is a
scientific question philosophy
philosophy arises in that context in
trying to address this basic existential
question that is of course still with us
today why do we even bother to show up
for our existence in the first place as
if we had it as if we had a choice in
the matter it was a way of trying to
think it out in very very human terms
this great moral quandary that was
roiling up beneath the normative
explosion how do we achieve a life that
matters philosophy is not going to go
away
because this question of what we can do
in order to achieve of life of maximum
mattering is always going to be is going
to be with us and philosophy is a way a
non-religious secular way of trying to
approach this question which I would
argue if I had two hours more has indeed
made a great deal of progress